* Anschwellende Trommelmusik *
Die Ecole hoteliere de Lausanne
gehört
zu den renommiertesten Handelsschulen
für die Hotelindustrie.
2'800 Studenten aus über 110 Nationen
streben an der EHL nach Exzellenz,
Können und Selbstbewusstsein.
Wir begleiten drei Studenten
im Vorbereitungsjahr
und zwei am Ende ihres Studiums.
Alexandre Charlaix, 18 Jahre alt.
Mit seiner Matura in der Tasche
geht er in das Vorbereitungsjahr.
Emma Pittet ist 21. Sie wurde
in der Genferseeregion geboren
und beginnt ihr Studium
an dieser internationalen Schule.
Genau wie Alexandre Attia,
19 Jahre alt.
Der Sohn eines Hoteliers geht mit
Selbstvertrauen ins erste Semester.
Annina von Falkenstein.
Mit 21 beginnt sie
ihr vorletztes Studienjahr.
Die junge Baslerin strebt
nach nichts weniger als Exzellenz.
Afrim Beqa ist 27
und startet sein letztes Semester.
Der energetische Afrim möchte
selbstständiger Unternehmer werden.
Letztes Mal in "Die Hotelfachschule":
Der junge Alex
beginnt seinen letzten Workshop:
den Service
im Gourmetrestaurant der Schule.
Generalprobe mit seinem Chef.
Madame,
es gibt zwei Menüs zur Auswahl,
die man nicht kombinieren kann.
Annina und ihr Team bereiten sich
auf das Abschlussdiplom vor.
Sie arbeiten an einem Business-
projekt für eine Grossbank.
Wer wird es präsentieren?
Vielleicht bin ich es.
Emma rennt
von einem Termin zum nächsten,
um ein Praktikum zu ergattern,
obligatorisch im Vorbereitungsjahr.
Ich hatte
schon zwei Vorstellungsgespräche,
ich bin also
nicht mehr so aufgeregt.
Alexandre hat sich sehr spät
um das Praktikum gekümmert.
Dank seines Vaters
hat er einen Termin
in einem Genfer Luxushotel bekommen.
Ich hoffe, dass alles gut läuft.
Ich weiss nicht,
wieso es nicht klappen sollte.
Afrim ist weit weg von den Sorgen
des Vorbereitungsjahres.
Für 200 seiner Mitabsolventen
hat er die Abschlussreise
nach Thailand organisiert.
Eine Woche Tropen,
dann zurück ins reale Leben.
Auf ihn wartet nun die Arbeitswelt.
Sehr cool, ich mag es,
mit Leuten zu diskutieren,
in einer Verkaufsatmosphäre.
Ein sonniger Morgen,
von dem Alex nicht profitiert.
Mitten im Praktikum rackert er sich
ab und ist ein wenig deprimiert.
So schönes Wetter.
Alex, kümmerst du dich
um den Staubsauger?
Kannst du auch
die Servietten falten?
Ja, okay,
Staubsauger, Servietten, alles gut.
Bis später.
Das Schwierigste an diesem Job:
arbeiten,
während die anderen frei haben.
Strebst du immer
noch eine Hotelkarriere an?
Ganz ehrlich? Nein.
Die Arbeitszeiten und so - ja, ich
habe es gesehen, und das reicht mir.
Dieser Lebensrhythmus
kackt mich jetzt schon an.
Nach den Osterferien habe ich
gemerkt, dass es echt Scheisse ist.
All meine Freunde sind draussen,
während ich arbeite. Das tut weh.
Auch Emma
macht in Genf ein Praktikum.
Und die Welt, die sie entdeckt,
gibt auch ihr
einen guten Grund zum Murren.
Ich arbeite pro Woche 7 Std. mehr
als in einem normalen Praktikum
in der Schweiz,
und jetzt wollen die sogar ein ärzt-
liches Zeugnis für 2 Std. Absenz.
Die sind nicht sehr korrekt.
Ich habe kein Mail, keine Kasse,
wie kann man ohne Kasse
an einer Rezeption arbeiten?
Die Kunden wollen Wechselgeld,
sie wollen bar zahlen.
Was tust du dann?
Ich sage:
"Moment, ich frage meine Kollegen."
Die Leute
halten mich für eine Touristin.
Was machst du hier?
Ich kaufe ein Pflaster,
um mein Tattoo zu kaschieren.
Ah, das musst du abdecken.
Sind die gut?
- Die nehme ich immer.
Und wenn du zu spät kommst?
Das sehen die nicht gerne,
v.a. da ich sehr oft verspätet bin,
wegen des Busverkehrs.
Ich denke,
das tolerieren sie jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich muss vermeiden,
ein schlechtes Bild abzugeben.
* Verspielte Jazzklänge *
Siehst du
einen grossen Unterschied zur Schule?
Ja, es ist nicht das Gleiche.
Hier ist man eben
wirklich im aktiven Leben.
Das hat mich
anfangs ziemlich geschockt.
Das erste Praktikum in der
Hotellerie ist ein bisschen hart.
Man wird mit den Problemen eines
ersten Praktikums konfrontiert,
das kennen wir alle,
wir haben alle mal so angefangen.
Zuerst zeigt man den Praktikanten,
was es heisst, wirklich zu arbeiten.
Bei Alex hat das glücklicherweise
nicht sehr lange gedauert:
Er versteht schnell,
was verlangt ist.
Er zeigt guten Einsatz,
was in diesem Berufsfeld
sehr wichtig ist.
Alex am Apparat, ich höre.
Okay, kein Problem.
Der Manager hat gesagt:
"Um 18.15 Uhr muss alles bereit sein
und dann das Briefing."
Ja, ich weiss.
* Verspielte Jazzklänge *
Annina und ihr Team
präsentieren ihre Abschlussarbeit
der Jury der EHL und der Grossbank,
die ihnen den Auftrag gegeben hat.
Ich präsentiere einzelne Konzepte
und am Schluss die Conclusion.
Mein Teamkollege erinnerte mich
daran, das sei wichtig,
und ich solle es
bitte nicht vermasseln.
Ihre Präsentation
findet unter Ausschluss
der Öffentlichkeit statt, oder fast.
Zurück in Lausanne geht Afrim in
seine überraschend günstige Wohnung.
900 Fr. im Monat, fast im Zentrum,
zweieinhalb Zimmer, 65 m2.
Ganz ehrlich, solche Wohnungen
gibt es nicht mehr oft.
Ich werde diese Wohnung
noch eine Weile behalten.
Wie viel Geld brauchst du im Monat?
Kommt darauf an,
wie oft ich ausgehe.
Eigentlich nicht wirklich viel.
Ich muss mein Handy,
die Wohnung, die Versicherungen
und ein paar Ausflüge bezahlen.
Das ist ja nicht viel.
Wie finanzierst du dein Leben?
Ich habe ein paar Nebenjobs und
plane, ein Restaurant zu eröffnen.
Ich suche noch den idealen Ort.
Das Ganze ist sehr teuer.
Ich will nicht Tausende von Franken
in einen Ort investieren,
der mir später nicht gefällt,
nicht ideal ist.
Ich schaue mir verschiedene Spots an
und sehe, was passiert.
Ich möchte
mein eigenes Business eröffnen.
Das wäre top.
Annina und ihre Kollegen
sind erleichtert,
ihre Präsentation beendet zu haben,
und sind nicht allzu besorgt,
während die Jury sich berät.
Wir sind zufrieden damit,
wie es lief.
Es ist gut, dass es vorbei ist.
Wir warten darauf,
wieder rein zu dürfen
und die Kommentare zu bekommen.
Die Nervosität
war vor der Präsentation grösser.
We need to clear the room first.
(Mann) Wir waren beeindruckt
von drei Dingen:
erstens von Ihnen allen persönlich,
zweitens von Ihren Resultaten
und drittens von der Qualität
Ihrer Präsentation.
Aber auch von der Dekoration,
die Sie installiert haben.
(Frau) Das ist die beste SBP-Gruppe,
die ich je begleitet habe.
Und auch die, die mir
am meisten Spass gemacht hat.
Ein Erfolg, von Annina und ihrem Team
erhofft und vorhergesehen.
Die Jury gratuliert
zur hervorragenden Projektarbeit.
Ich bin erleichtert und
sehr glücklich darüber, wie es lief.
Bei den Kommentaren unserer
Klienten, aber auch der Coaches
kamen mir fast die Tränen.
Weil es einfach mega schön war,
dass sie erkannt haben, dass wir
als Gruppe gut zusammenarbeiten.
Das bedeutet mir viel. Denn es gibt
viele Studenten und Projekte.
Es ist wirklich cool.
* Verspielte Jazzklänge *
Emma zeigt uns ihr Zimmer,
das sie in Genf gemietet hat.
Die Küche.
Die Katze Gibsy.
Das Zimmer.
Bis wann arbeitest du?
- Mitternacht.
Ich will nicht gehen.
Wie waren die ersten Tage?
- Es war stressig.
Ich kam in einer hektischen Phase,
da war der Autosalon,
es gab Personalwechsel.
Ich habe einige Fehler gemacht.
Ein Kunde hätte 3'000 Fr. zahlen
müssen, und ich habe es vergessen.
Er ist gegangen, aber ich glaube,
das hat sich geklärt.
Ich habe einem Kunden
ein ungereinigtes Zimmer zugewiesen.
Mir wurde gesagt,
dass ich besser aufpassen muss.
Es ist einfach schwierig
in dieser Phase,
wenn man neu in ein Team kommt
und gar nichts weiss.
Und die Kunden
haben vielleicht nicht verstanden,
warum ich gewisse Fragen
nicht beantworten konnte.
Es war stressig.
Wie viel
bezahlen Sie den Praktikanten?
Den Mindestlohn für ein Praktikum:
1'979 Fr.
Für Alex
schlägt die Stunde des Briefings -
ein unausweichliches Ritual, wenn
man in einem Luxushotel arbeitet.
Heute Abend: Marion im Saal
und Alex hinten im Chalet.
Alex: Tisch decken für elf Personen.
Sechs vorne und fünf gegenüber.
Der Privatsalon
ist im Chaletstil gehalten.
Elf Leute -
zwei, vier, sechs, acht, zehn.
Ich soll diesen Tisch machen.
Ich habe Glück,
er ist schon fast komplett gedeckt.
Mal schauen, ob sein Vorgesetzter
auch dieser Meinung ist.
Nein, stell das so hin,
gegenüber vom Gast, wenn er kommt.
Wo ist das Besteck für den Fisch?
Ich hab dir doch gesagt,
sechs auf dieser Seite
und fünf auf der anderen.
Und den Teller nicht auf dem Set.
Verzeihung, Chef.
- Kein Problem.
Vorhin habe ich ihn gefragt:
"Fischbesteck?"
Er hat gesagt: "Nein."
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Okay."
Und jetzt fragt er:
"Wo ist das Fischbesteck?"
Danke schön!
Alexandre ist dafür verantwortlich,
die Menüteller aus der Küche dahin zu
bringen, wo die Kellner übernehmen.
Man muss aufmerksam sein, der Chef
ruft ständig: "Illago, illago!"
Dann muss alles schnell gehen.
Eine warme Mahlzeit
darf nicht kalt werden.
Man muss die Tickets
gut organisieren,
um genau zu wissen,
was man wo und wann servieren muss.
Es ist 11.35 Uhr,
ich muss noch aufräumen,
sollte um Mitternacht fertig sein.
Und morgen um 10 Uhr
wieder anfangen.
Das werden sechs schwierige Monate.
Dieselbe Leier für Alex,
unter den Augen seines Chefs.
Ich habe alles Brot weggeräumt, ich
habe alle Kühlschränke geschlossen,
die Spülmaschine ausgeschaltet.
- Ich kontrolliere das.
Der muss immer alles kontrollieren,
bevor ich gehen kann.
Noch nicht fertig?
- Gerade fertig geworden.
Ah, yes!
Das war krank, Alter!
So was habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Der Chef hat einen Praktikanten
voll angebrüllt, er schrie:
"Verdammte Scheisse!
Verpiss dich, du bist gefeuert!"
"Morgen sehe ich deine Scheiss-
papiere auf meinem Schreibtisch
und dann bist du raus." Was?
Der Platz der Praktikanten
ist ganz unten auf der Leiter.
Und einige Chefs
lassen ihren Frust an ihnen aus.
Manchmal, als ich gehen wollte,
sagte er:
"Stopp, es gibt noch
dies und das zu erledigen."
Als Praktikant dachte ich: "Okay,
ich halte meine Klappe und mach es."
Das nervte mich, er wartete immer
bis kurz vor Schluss,
um mir das zu sagen,
und du kannst nichts machen.
* Verspielte Glockenklänge *
Wonder-Annina und ihr Topteam kommen,
um ihre Arbeit einer Direktionsdele-
gation der Grossbank vorzustellen,
die sie beauftragt hat.
Nervös?
- Ein bisschen.
Aufgeregt.
- Okay, very good.
Unsere Recherchen haben ergeben,
dass junge Leute die Bank
als nicht transparent wahrnehmen.
Hier sind unsere Ideen,
um diesen Ruf zu korrigieren.
Ihre Leuchtturmidee:
die Schweizer Universitäten besuchen,
um Studenten eine gute
finanzielle Beratung zu bieten.
Ich glaube,
an der Uni St. Gallen z.B.
hat eine andere Bank das Monopol.
Ja, die ist dort schon aktiv.
Könnten wir uns da
überhaupt noch positionieren?
Könnte schwierig sein, nicht?
* Unverständliche Antwort *
Ups, ein kleines Problem.
Das Team kann die aufgeworfene Frage
nicht beantworten.
Mein nächstes Meeting ist in 2 Min.
Ich bin schon fast verspätet.
Aber ich möchte Ihnen gratulieren.
Sie haben eine wirklich
beeindruckende Arbeit abgeliefert.
Vielen Dank!
Danke, dass Sie uns empfangen haben.
Wir arbeiten regelmässig
mit Schülern der EHL.
Die sind für mich sehr interessant,
weil sie einen Vorteil mitbringen.
Das sind Leute mit Selbstbewusstsein
und einer perfekten Haltung,
die ich suche.
Und mit der richtigen Einstellung
lernt man alles.
Dass sie sich noch nicht
in der Finanzwelt auskennen,
ist für mich kein Problem.
Was zählt, ist die gute Einstellung.
So kann man alles erreichen,
was man will.
Serge und ich stellten
in der Fragerunde überrascht fest,
dass die junge Generation gar nicht
so anders ist als unsere Generation.
Und dass der menschliche Kontakt
doch noch sehr wichtig ist.
Wir haben vielleicht
doch ein paar falsche Vorstellungen
von der Generation Y
oder der Digitalisierungswelt.
Es braucht doch noch den Menschen
neben all diesen Hilfsmitteln.
Emma trifft ihre Zwillingsschwester
Juliette im Haus ihres Vaters.
Emma hat gerade eine Zeit
voller Wendungen hinter sich.
Sie ist nicht sicher,
ob die unerbittliche Welt
der grossen Hotels ihr Ding ist.
Ich habe entschieden, das Praktikum
frühzeitig abzubrechen,
aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Ich musste dann, während ich
noch im Intercontinental arbeitete,
den ganzen EHL-Papierkram erledigen,
für die Bestätigung
eines neuen Praktikums.
Ich musste schnell reagieren.
Emma hat ein neues Praktikum
in Lausanne gefunden.
Eine Gelegenheit,
näher bei ihrer Familie zu sein.
Ja, ich war in den letzten Jahren
nicht oft zu Hause
bei meinen Eltern, meiner Schwester.
Wie ist das Zusammenleben?
Na ja, es geht.
Man gewöhnt sich dran.
Direction baignade!
Das Praktikum von Alex in Genf
hat ihm erlaubt,
seinen Zwillingsbruder
regelmässig zu sehen.
Aber Loris schaut sehr ironisch auf
den Weg, den sein Bruder gewählt hat.
Er würde sagen: "Ich werde bezahlt,
um Guacamole zu machen."
Nein,
die EHL ist eine sehr gute Schule.
Aber ich denke, er ist sich nicht
des Glücks bewusst, das er hat.
Er kann nur
auf diese renommierte Schule,
weil wir die finanziellen Mittel
dazu haben.
Halt die Klappe! Stimmt gar nicht.
Ich habe die sechs Monate
einigermassen ausgehalten ohne ihn,
aber es ist jetzt schön,
ihn wiederzusehen.
Es ist normal, dass in diesem Alter
jeder seinen Weg geht.
Als Zwillinge machen wir
viele Faxen, die nur wir verstehen,
weil wir viel zusammen sind.
Der Nachteil von Zwillingsbrüdern:
Man sollte immer gleich sein.
Es ist schwierig,
Kritik voneinander zu akzeptieren.
Aber es gibt
eine unglaubliche Verbundenheit.
Deux, trois.
* Pulsierende Musik *
Die Wochen vergehen, und Alexandre
schaut zurück auf sein Praktikum.
Ein Geschmack von Deja-vu -
wie damals, als ihm an der EHL
die Leviten gelesen wurden.
Vom 2. bis zum 3.,
also kurz vor den Ferien,
war ich in einer negativen Phase.
Ich hatte eine Diskussion
mit dem Manager.
Er sagte, es sei nicht in Ordnung,
wie ich arbeite.
Das höre ich natürlich nicht gerne.
Aber es war die Wahrheit.
Ich merkte nicht,
wie negativ geladen ich war.
Ich will kein schlechtes Bild
von mir abgeben.
Ich habe im Praktikum
einige Sachen gelernt,
bin reifer geworden.
Ich weiss jetzt,
wie die wahre Arbeitswelt aussieht,
habe jetzt grossen Respekt
vor all den Menschen,
die diesen harten Beruf
ein Leben lang ausüben.
Für mich als vielleicht zukünftiger
Hotelier war es wichtig,
das zu verstehen,
wenn ich diese Leute führe.
Das war eine Erleuchtung für mich.
* Gedämpfter französischer Hip-Hop *
(Frau) Heute schauen wir uns
die berühmten Prioritäten an.
Wie läuft's beim Praktikum?
Es geht. Es geht immer besser,
denn ich lerne das Metier
immer besser kennen
und ich habe mehr Freiheiten.
Da unten scharf rechts abbiegen!
- Ja.
Chef!
- Ja, Chef!
Alex macht den Führerschein.
Bei Weitem nicht die einzige Prüfung,
die auf ihn wartet.
Das Problem ist,
dass ich Prüfungen nachholen muss.
Nachprüfungen?
- Ja, drei sogar.
Stewarding ... Patisserie,
Produktion und Gourmetküche.
Kostet das was?
Ja, verdammt, 300 Fr. pro Prüfung.
Kannst du dir das vorstellen?
Das ist Diebstahl.
Eine Prüfung 300?
- Ja, unglaublich.
Wie viele musst du machen?
- Drei.
900.
Zum Glück werde ich bezahlt,
und lebe bei Mama,
wohne und esse gratis.
Denk mal an die,
die das nicht alles haben!
Küsschen. Vielen Dank noch mal.
Profites bien a Lisbonne alors.
Auch Alexandre
wird Nachprüfungen ablegen müssen.
Einige.
Die muss ich Ende August machen.
Ich werde Ende Monat beginnen,
mich vorzubereiten,
denn wenn ich eine Prüfung versaue,
könnte ich sechs Monate lang
nicht weitermachen an der EHL
und müsste im Februar antreten.
Jetzt habe ich keine Zeit
für Freunde.
Während seiner Pause
trifft Alexandre seinen Vater,
der in einem benachbarten Luxushotel
auf ihn wartet.
Hallo, Papa.
- Salut, Alex. Ca va?
Ist die Terrasse ausgebucht?
- Die ist voll.
Eine super Erfahrung, nicht?
Eine gute Grundlage,
das Geschäft zu lernen.
Es hat mir die Augen
für das Metier geöffnet,
ich habe einiges verstanden.
Das ist die Grundlage.
Es ist eines
der komplexesten Berufsfelder,
und eines der schwierigsten
zum Organisieren.
Man muss viel wissen.
In der Hotellerie
gibt es drei Berufsbereiche:
die Beherbergung,
das Restaurant und die Immobilie.
Das Restaurant ist unser Metier:
die Küche, der Service
und alles, was damit zusammenhängt.
Auch das ist sehr komplex.
Hinzu kommt die Immobilie,
in die wir investieren.
Ein Hotel hat schöne Räumlichkeiten
und Zimmer.
Das ist eine grosse Investition.
Diese drei Bereiche muss man kennen,
um ein Hotel zu führen.
Du bist auf bestem Weg,
das alles kennenzulernen.
Ich bin zufrieden mit dir, es ist
hart, aber da musst du jetzt durch.
Wenn man mich fragt,
wer mein Held ist,
sag ich: "Es ist mein Vater."
Er hat es geschafft,
sich selbstständig zu machen.
Er ist mein Vorbild.
Am Seeufer von Lausanne
beginnt Emma ihr neues Praktikum.
Ein freundlicherer Ort
als das Grand Hotel in Genf,
wo sie ein bisschen gelitten hat.
Hier fühlt sie sich viel besser.
Eine Restaurantbar direkt am See,
mit 360 Grad Aussicht auf den See.
* Musik und Gelächter *
Ich komme gleich wieder
mit den Karten.
Hier sind die Speisen,
die Pizzen sind dort beim Ofen,
der Rest direkt hier in der Küche.
Ich habe Mühe damit,
nur drinnen zu arbeiten,
ohne Tageslicht.
Im Intercontinental
waren es 8-10 Std.
Hier bin ich immer draussen, ich
kann während der Pausen baden gehen.
Es ist toll,
das Team versteht sich super.
Wir haben Zeit, uns kennenzulernen.
Das Intercontinental
war eine ganz andere Welt.
Dort hatten wir
sehr lange Tage und keine Zeit,
um wirklich zusammenzuarbeiten
und uns kennenzulernen.
* Verspielte Jazzklänge *
Annina und ihre WG
kochen eines der letzten Essen,
das sie gemeinsam einnehmen.
Gestern konnte ich den Vertrag
unterschrieben zurückschicken.
Es sieht so aus, als ziehe es mich
für die Arbeit nach Bern.
Als Direktions-
und Human-Resources-Assistentin.
20 % Direktion,
80 % Human Resources - je nachdem.
Damit bin ich sehr, sehr zufrieden.
Ich freue mich darauf.
(Alle) Zum Wohl.
Ich habe
etwas weniger Sirup reingetan.
Beim berüchtigten Partyleben der
Studenten hat Annina kaum mitgemacht.
Ich bin durchaus dafür zu haben,
mal in eine Bar zu gehen.
Aber ich finde es schade,
nächtelang bei lauter Musik
mit Menschen Zeit zu verbringen,
die einem gar nicht so nahestehen,
wenn man eigentlich schlafen könnte.
Im Schulleben
ist jeweils so viel los,
man kommt gar nicht dazu,
mit seinen Freuenden zu reden.
Gerade, wenn man im Unterricht
nicht im selben Team ist.
Ich verbringe solche Abende dann
eben lieber mit meinen Freunden.
Ende einer Ära,
Ende des WG-Lebens nach drei Jahren.
Es war eine super Zeit.
Es tut weh, auszuziehen.
V.a., wenn man nicht weiss,
was danach kommt.
Und jetzt ist es doch so gut.
Aber es ist oft so:
Es ist auch darum so gut,
weil man weiss,
dass es nicht für immer ist.
Ich glaube, es hört nicht auf,
wenn es am besten ist,
sondern es ist am besten,
weil es bald aufhört.
Ich habe die Weisheit
mit Löffeln gegessen.
* Verspielte Jazzklänge *
Letzte Stunden im Luxushotel, in dem
Alexandre sein Praktikum beendet.
Heute ist er gar nicht in Form.
Ich war schon lange
nicht mehr so müde von der Arbeit.
Ich habe
ein bisschen Abschied gefeiert
und die letzten Nächte
wenig geschlafen.
Wirst du die Kollegen vermissen?
- Einige ja, andere nicht.
Mit einigen gab es Schwierigkeiten.
Das hält sich die Waage.
Wie verlief das Praktikum
mit Alexandre?
Kompliziert. Hart.
Es ist immer schwierig
mit den Jungen.
Es ist unser Job,
diese Burschen erfolgreich
auf die Zukunft vorzubereiten.
Ich hoffe, wir haben ihm
etwas Positives beigebracht.
Der letzte Morgen des Praktikums
für Emma,
die den Hochbetrieb fast vermisst.
Schlechtes Wetter. Schade, ich glau-
be, die Leute bleiben in der Stadt.
Wir haben
keinen Fünf-Sterne-Anspruch,
weder vom Niveau her
noch von den Uniformen.
Wir versuchen jedoch, wenigstens
einen Fünf-Sterne-Service zu bieten,
auch wenn das
nicht offensichtlich ist.
Emma hat sich schnell angepasst an
unseren Rhythmus, das schätze ich.
Man muss hin- und herrennen.
Emma hat sich toll entwickelt.
* Schiffshorn *
Ich habe sie bereits
für nächste Woche eingeteilt.
Sie wird weiter hier arbeiten
während des Studiums,
natürlich je nach Verfügbarkeit.
Das Vorbereitungsjahr
war ja kein Studium,
deshalb freue ich mich,
jetzt wirklich zu studieren.
Es werden regelmässigere
Arbeitsstunden sein,
das wird mir gut tun.
Der letzte Tag,
von Alex sehnlichst erwartet.
Ich bin glücklich,
das Praktikum nun abzuschliessen.
Es hat Spass gemacht, aber
ich bin froh, dass es fertig ist.
Es war lang und hart.
Und nach diesen sechs Monaten
werde ich drei Nachprüfungen
schreiben müssen.
Nächsten Mittwoch,
Donnerstag und Freitag.
Die Praktikanten sind zu
einem Abschiedsaperitif eingeladen.
Ich muss nachschauen,
in welchem Saal es ist.
Bonjour.
Waren sie hart, die sechs Monate?
- Ja. Anstrengend.
Sie sind ja hier, um zu lernen,
nicht? Sie waren hier.
Noch sind wir da.
Schreibt einen Hashtag,
ein Schlüsselwort,
das eure Erfahrung beschreibt!
(Mann) Un mot cle?
- (Frau) Un mot cle.
Darf ich beginnen? #proud.
Weil ich stolz darauf bin,
was dieses Unternehmen
für mich gemacht hat.
Und dass ich in schwierigen
Situationen nicht aufgegeben habe.
Gut gemacht!
Ist dir klar geworden,
wie wichtig das Bild ist,
das du von dir vermittelst?
Ja, ich weiss,
dass ich nicht immer so seriös bin.
In der Schule
kann man Faxen machen und sagen:
"Nicht schlimm,
der ist ja noch ein Kind."
Aber in der Arbeitswelt musst du
dich benehmen wie ein Erwachsener.
A tout bientot.
- Bonne soiree.
Sie ist weg,
jetzt lassen wir es knallen!
Es ist auch
die Stunde der Bilanz für Alexandre.
Mein Charakter
hat es mir schwer gemacht.
Ich bin offen und ehrlich,
ich habe einige
Verbesserungsvorschläge gemacht,
aber es wurde immer als arrogant
und respektlos empfunden.
Ich bin in einem Hotel aufgewachsen,
und ich sehe,
was funktioniert und was nicht.
Ich war der Einzige, der mutig genug
war, die Dinge beim Namen zu nennen.
Das hat viele Probleme verursacht.
Ein langes und hartes Jahr
geht zu Ende.
Das Praktikum
hat mir die Augen geöffnet.
Mein Vater ist Hotelier.
Deshalb wollte ich
in dieses Metier einsteigen.
Aber ich habe gesehen:
Das ist nicht meine Domäne.
Vielleicht werde ich Manager
oder Besitzer eines Hotels,
das wäre interessant.
Aber in der Hotellerie selbst
arbeiten? Nein.
* Aufgestellte Musik *
Hat Annina die angestrebten zehn
von zehn Exzellenzpunkten erreicht?
Ich bin stolz auf dich.
Die Diplomfeier:
Für Annina ist es die Krönung.
(Mann auf der Bühne)
Abschluss mit High Honours:
Annina Elsa Maria von Falkenstein.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Die Grossmutter nimmt Teil
am Triumph ihrer brillanten Enkelin.
(Alle im Chor) EHL! EHL!
Draussen wird das Ehrenspalier
schnurgerade ausgerichtet.
* Jazzmusik, Stimmengewirr *
Ich habe mein Ziel erreicht,
ich habe High Honors bekommen.
Ich bin sehr stolz, denn ich habe
lange darauf hingearbeitet.
Zeitweise sah es nicht so aus,
als würde es klappen.
Ich bin viel unabhängiger
und selbstständiger.
Anfangs
war ich noch etwas unsicherer.
Jetzt fällt es mir viel leichter,
auf Menschen zuzugehen.
Ich habe mich gefunden,
was wahrscheinlich
auch normal ist in dem Alter.
Aber ich lernte mich
durch die Challenges besser kennen.
In Praktika, Gruppenprojekten,
Teams von Unbekannten.
Sobald man sich wohlfühlte,
wurde man weitergepusht.
So erreicht man Grenzen,
die man zuvor nicht kannte.
Monate sind vergangen
seit dem Abschluss von Afrim,
aber er bereitet seine Zukunft vor,
ohne Überstürzung.
D e n  Job finden, ja.
Aber nicht irgendeinen.
Wenn ich in einem Jahr
nicht das finde, was ich will,
breche ich ab.
Es ist cool, Leute zu treffen,
aber ich muss ja
meine Wohnung etc. bezahlen.
Solange ich so weitermachen kann,
werde ich es auch tun.
Wenn ich die Hoffnung verliere,
sehen wir weiter.
Ich bin sehr wagemutig.
Aber zurzeit
stehe ich nicht unter Druck.
Auf geht's!
Heute ist auch für Afrim
ein ganz besonderer Tag.
Er nimmt an einer
einzigartigen Zeremonie teil.
Jetzt kannst du dich noch
über diese Ausländer beschweren,
aber in ein paar Minuten
sind alle Schweizer.
Das ist die letzte Chance.
Ich habe aber
schon ein paar Fehler gesehen.
Ein paar sind mit dem Taxi gekommen
und stellen sich nicht hinten an,
sondern drängen direkt rein.
Nicht sehr schweizerisch.
Die haben den Pass noch nicht.
Was wird sich verändern -
ganz konkret?
Vieles. V.a. für jemanden,
der einen kosovarischen Pass hat,
der nicht in allen Ländern
akzeptiert wird.
Es gibt Länder,
in die ich gar nicht reinkomme.
Ich wollte z.B. mal mit der Schule
nach China, Hongkong,
aber es war für mich nicht möglich.
Sobald ich als Kosovare
Europa verlassen wollte,
brauchte ich ein Visum,
eine Riesenprozedur.
Meine Damen und Herren,
guten Tag und herzlich willkommen.
Alle erforderlichen Formalitäten des
Waadtländer Gesetzes sind erfüllt,
ausser der Zeremonie,
zu der Sie einberufen worden sind.
Wir beginnen diese Zeremonie mit
der Lektüre der gesetzlichen Formel.
Nachdem Ihr Name
aufgerufen worden ist,
heben Sie die rechte Hand und sagen:
"Ich gelobe es."
* Ein Name wird aufgerufen. *
Je le promets.
Amatai Afrim.
- (Flüsternd) Noch ein Afrim.
* Ein Name wird aufgerufen. *
Beqa Afrim.
Ich gelobe es.
3.1?
- Oui, merci beaucoup.
Felicitations.
- Merci.
Gratulation.
Wie viele Jahre Integration?
- 28 Jahre.
Ich weiss noch nicht,
ob ich es verdient habe.
Aber ich fühle mich gut.
Wirst du dieses Diplom einrahmen?
- Das wäre es schon wert.
* Treibende elektronische Klänge *
Dieses Sommerende
ist entscheidend für Alexandre.
Ich bin heute hier, um
die Bäckereiprüfung zu wiederholen.
Ich habe mich gut vorbereitet,
ich weiss nicht,
wieso es nicht klappen sollte.
Ich bin zuversichtlich und hoffe, zu
bestehen, um mein Jahr fortzusetzen.
Die letzte von drei Prüfungen.
Das wird klappen.
Drei Nachprüfungen?
Ja, drei. In der ersten 74 von 80,
in der zweiten 76 von 80 Punkten.
Und nun schauen wir mal.
* Spannende Klänge *
Kommst du von der Prüfung?
- Ja.
Es gab technische Probleme
mit den Tablets,
deshalb
sind wir ein wenig verspätet.
Es waren
nicht alle Fragen verfügbar.
Das wurde geklärt, ich bin
vor einigen Minuten fertig geworden.
Die Ergebnisse? Spannung.
Alex
muss noch die Nachprüfungen bezahlen.
Das ist Teil des Spiels.
Logisch, dass ich es bezahle
und nicht meine Mutter.
Bitte hier unterschreiben.
Ich habe eine Dummheit gemacht,
war zu spät,
und nehme die Konsequenzen in Kauf,
auch wenn es viel kostet.
* Gemütliche Jazzmelodie *
Annina hat beschlossen,
so schnell wie möglich
in die Arbeitswelt einzusteigen.
Sie hat ihren Wunschjob gefunden -
beim Personaldienst
eines grossen Berner Hotels.
Okay, 27., 28., 29., 30., 31.
Also fünf Tage.
Fünf Tage.
- Der 27. wäre sowieso zu spät.
Ja, das Valuta war am 28.
Das wäre also sowieso durch gewesen.
Genau.
Ich persönlich brauchte kein Zwi-
schenjahr bzw. keine Reiseerfahrung
nach Abschluss des Studiums.
Denn es hat sich so gut ergeben,
dass ich diese Stelle
hier im Bellevue bekommen habe,
dass es für mich einfach stimmte,
direkt ins Berufsleben zu starten.
Ich arbeite sehr gerne.
Darum bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Auch wenn es rasch
nach dem Abschluss an der EHL ist.
Für unsere ehemaligen
Vorbereitungsjahr-Studierenden
heisst es zurück an die Schule.
Die Ergebnisse der Nachprüfungen
sind nun bekannt.
Ich habe eine von zwölf Prüfungen
versaut, Weinkunde.
Elf habe ich bestanden.
Ich falle wegen 0,15 Punkten durch
und kann nicht weitermachen.
Ich bin sehr enttäuscht
und wütend auf mich selbst.
Ich muss die Prüfungen
im Februar erneut wiederholen,
verliere viereinhalb Monate Zeit.
Trotzdem gebe ich nie auf
bei Fehlschlägen.
Ich denke positiv,
und ich werde alles geben,
damit das nicht erneut geschieht.
Alex hat bestanden und bestaunt
die Baustelle des neuen Campus.
Er wird erst fertig,
wenn wir weg sind.
Verdammt!
Wir haben's geschafft, Jungs!
Auch Emma ist zurück.
Froh? Ja, aber auf ihre Weise.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst,
aber ich werde es schaffen.
Ich gebe mein Bestes, um
keine Nachprüfung machen zu müssen.
Das kostet viel und ist mühsam.
Aber du musst
keine Nachprüfung machen?
Nein, ich habe glücklicherweise
alle Prüfungen
mit gutem Durchschnitt bestanden.
Ich bin froh.
Und hier ist Monsieur Laurent,
der Botschafter der Werte,
der immer gerne Witze macht.
Willkommen zurück.
Nur kurz:
Es gibt ganz viele Veränderungen.
Und wenn Sie mit Veränderungen
nicht klarkommen,
kommen Sie auch
mit Herausforderungen nicht zurecht.
Vergessen Sie das nicht!
Aber ich habe noch
eine sehr gute Nachricht:
Bei der Kleiderordnung gibt es ...
keine Änderung.
* Lachen *
Der Dresscode ist unverrückbar,
aber sonst hat sich alles verändert.
Alexandre bekam eine Lektion.
Wird er die Konsequenzen ziehen?
Emma hat die schwierige Welt
eines grossen Hotels kennengelernt.
Wie wird sie sich entscheiden?
Alex findet, dass er nicht
für die Hotelwelt gemacht ist.
Welche Richtung wird er einschlagen?
Afrim wägt Pro und Kontra ab.
Wird er den Job seiner Träume finden?
Kann Annina
den Kurs der Exzellenz beibehalten?
Die Hotelfachschule Lausanne
ist wie ein Bienenhaus,
in dem Tausende Menschen
sich begegnen, zusammenleben,
und dann in allen Richtungen
ihren Honig suchen.